[Music]
I've always identified myself being a
knock I just didn't have that
understanding as a kid like what that
actually meant
Marissa St Goddard has a foot in Two
Worlds born to an Enoch mother adopted
by a non-indigenous couple she was
raised just outside Winnipeg I was
adopted at nine months old it was
something that I really struggled with I
guess throughout life it was mainly that
sense of belonging that I couldn't
really get a handle on then she came
here
is the Winnipeg Art gallery's new center
for Inuit art and culture honestly ever
since working at the art gallery that's
when it really started to really feel
connected
her passion is art ever since she was a
kid nothing was off limits to her
crayons pencils markers everything has
been a canvas it was always something
that just brought me a lot of joy and
the gallery is taking her to a whole new
level she guides tour groups mostly
young people through Inuit exhibits and
the work of other indigenous artists
and what are we going into Robert hewell
today the best part about like teaching
young kids about my culture is just
something that really it does a little
something in here and I'm just it's so
cool to see that this next generation of
kids that are just so open about
learning about it when you say it does a
little something in here what do you
mean it just kind of like brightens my
soul a little bit I'd say when I'm in
the moment doing it I just Everything
feels lighter in fact kamoyuk means it
is bright it is lit in a Nook the
gallery opened in early 2021 in downtown
Winnipeg it is the world's largest
public collection of contemporary Inuit
art the centerpiece is What's called the
visible Vault curated by Darlene coward
White
there's 4 500 pieces in here and all of
these are Stone
because of the environmental conditions
here it's three stories of Inuit art two
above ground and one below our whale
born our Ivory and our antler is down
below there are pieces from 25
communities here spanning Generations
art that was once safely stored out of
public view is now the first thing
visitors see when they walk in we really
wanted to be able to show the world that
here they are you don't have to pay a
fee to see our visible Vault we have the
communities all on display here we
really wanted to make it more accessible
that was the big thing Darlene has
researched and curated Inuit art for
close to 40 years the more that people
know about other cultures I think the
more opportunities we have for Mutual
understanding and empathy we are trying
to bridge that Gap to help people
understand and to see it here right from
this start the gallery worked with Inuit
Elders community members and knowledge
Keepers in every step of the process is
reimagining the relationship with Inuit
artists and communities we're very
interested in the transparency and the
communication in the inclusiveness
what we're doing we're trying very hard
to get Beyond a colonial attitude
towards art any weed in their ancestors
have been skilled artists and Carvers
for thousands of years what we know is
contemporary Inuit art began in 1949
around the time when artist James
Houston organized an exhibition with
pieces he bought during trips to the
north the exhibition was popular with
collectors and the federal government
which was looking for ways to get the
north on a wage economy it wanted Inuit
communities to make art for money
accelerating a shift away from
traditional ways of life art was sold
and shipped to Market through the
Hudson's Bay Company and later through
community-owned co-ops a number of
regions flourished and they remain hubs
for internationally renowned Inuit
artists but many others struggled
[Music]
conversations about the ethics of
colonial Arts systems like this are
happening in galleries across the
country
also known as Mohawk of the hodnishone
Confederacy my home Community is the six
nations of the Grand River but I now
have the honor and privilege of living
and working on unseated unsurrendered
territory of the anishinaabe Algonquin
Nation last year the National Gallery in
Ottawa launched the department of
indigenous ways and decolonization
Stephen loft is the vice president for
the first time in this institution's
80-year history you have not won but two
indigenous people at the highest level
of decision making
institutions don't change themselves
people change institutions
that means embedding indigenous voices
and expertise in all aspects of the
National Gallery there's an indigenous
art history of this land there's
indigenous artistries from other lands
we're starting to understand the
plurality of cultural expression
and getting away from this notion of the
dominance of one kind Stephen wants the
National Gallery to be a global leader
in that new way of understanding
indigenous art though he admits not
everyone is on board you're always going
to get that pushback because this is
about power and privilege and
institutions like this are built on
Power and privilege we have to reconcile
with that history as well but we have to
move forward and by moving forward we
commit to a much more not just inclusive
but Equitable understanding culture and
I think that's exciting work 30 years
ago we didn't have the the language to
really think about what decolonizing a
space would mean and I think now there's
a lot more dialogue with indigenous
non-indigenous folks that challenge sort
of those those hierarchies or those very
oppressive structures that are quite
harmful
gland gear is a multi-disciplinary
artist and filmmaker living in Montreal
I'm originally from Corner Brook
Newfoundland and I come from Inuit and
settler ancestry my father is eNook from
a place called alatook Bay Labrador
nazielvot and my mother is
newfoundlander with Irish and English
background Glenn calls himself an urban
inook and like many artists of his
generation his work is a reflection of
his past and present it's video art it's
performance it's textiles it's based in
so many different mediums it's you know
painting and drawing it's not just the
prince and sculptures of of yesteryear I
mean it continues to be that but it's so
much more
this is one of the collages that I did
from some of the photo archives in
Labrador
[Applause]
Glenn was commissioned to create a piece
for kamayuk's opening the installation
was called iluani silami it's full of
stars
it's very much a space of reflection but
also it's it's a love letter to Labrador
in a container
[Music]
dad
action to the land and culture and
Labrador the focus of the Inuit stories
he explores through his art a lot of the
titles of my works are in Inuit from my
region that's important for me to kind
of reclaim that language because it was
very broken with my father him being a
child of the residential school system
he didn't have inertitude as his
language even though his mother my
grandmother spoke it fluently when I
started to dive into my father's history
which you know I share that history with
him I began to understand maybe some of
the cultural breaks that were there and
the ways that he couldn't speak about
his culture or his connection to Inuit
culture that look into his own history
is painstaking but rewarding part of my
work is an act of repair and Remediation
of that whole process of of trying to
reconnect trying to understand the
language and learn it one word at a time
there's joy with within that process of
struggling through language and
struggling through culture and making
those connections
in Winnipeg Marissa is going through
that process too I think this one was
like my favorite though this one I
remember I always loved like the art
style in this book too my mom would
always read me like these anyway books
that she would buy all based around
anyway arts and anyway people I was like
oh like I kind of look like these people
and in a way it sort of gave me a sense
of belonging
she has formed relationships with some
of her Inuit relatives and learned more
about their history that combined with
her art is helping her create a
narrative about who she is these are
most of the artworks that I've done
throughout High School
art in general is I think like a therapy
whether if it's to get your mind off of
things or expressing yourself with how
you're feeling I was printing that one
and at the time my headspace was in a
point of healing it was in a point of
growth finding New Perspectives of
everything like based on life and the
piece right beside it like the woman
here she represents to me just like that
sense of like self accepting like who
you are as a person
I'm just really excited to be here today
to show you guys some art Marissa is
helping kids discover their own Voice
through ART I'm just kind of taking the
brush and
um doing like these back and forth up
and down kind of movements to give it
that streaky look so that it kind of
looks like the Northern Lights
together with a colleague she's teaching
a virtual art class to kids in remote
Arctic communities I think it's super
powerful to learn about who you are as a
person but then share it with others at
the same time as Marissa and other young
Inuit artists create a new path for
themselves the gallery is showcasing
what's possible for the future I think
things have really shifted right now
with the way that galleries think about
how they engage different communities
indigenous communities how they engage
curators and how they are more open to
hearing what new voices are emerging and
especially what youth have to say and
how they engage in those Gallery spaces
it's a really exciting time for Inuit
art and Inuit artists art is definitely
something that I do see in my future I
don't know what I'm gonna do with it but
we'll see what the universe has aligned
up